>> Tucker: SENATOR ELIZABETH
THAT DIDN'T SLOW HER DOWN
FROM SUBMITTING RECIPES TO
AN NATIVE AMERICAN COOK
PECULIAR POWWOW CHOW FOR
REAL.
SEVERAL RECIPES PLAGIARIZED
TOO.
WHY GET HUNG UP ON THAT.
HOW DO INDIAN RECIPES STACK
UP AS FOOD?
WE GOT A COPY THE BOOK AND
DECIDED TO INVESTIGATE WITH
PROFESSIONAL CHEF AND
COOKBOOK AUTHOR MARK BAILEY.
MARK BAILEY, THANKS FOR
JOINING US.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: THERE HAS BEEN A
LOT OF CONTROVERSY AROUND
ELIZABETH WARREN'S NATIVE
AMERICAN HERITAGE AS YOU
KNOW.
>> UM-HUH.
>> Tucker: A LOT OF PEOPLE
WEIGHED IN ON IT WE THOUGHT
ONE THE RECIPES SHE DONATED
TO A BOOK POW COW CHOW.
NATIVE AMERICANS CONTRIBUTED
RECIPES FROM HER TRIBE.
WE HERE ASKING HOW.
HOW THIS DISH IS MADE.
HER TRIBE OF COURSE THE
>> COLD OMELET WITH CRAB
MEAT.
I NEVER HEARD OF THIS.
I'M VERY EXCITED.
IT'S A COLD OMELET.
>> ACTUALLY USED AS A
DRESSING WHICH IS
INTERESTING.
THE OMELET IS FLAT AS A
MORE GIRTH TO IT.
THIS IS FLAT AS A PANCAKE.
>> Tucker: I DON'T WANT TO
BEGIN ON SKEPTICAL NOTE.
CRAB MEAT YOU DON'T THINK AS
THE CHEROKEE AS A SEA FARING
TWIST.
>> Tucker: LITTLE TWIST.
WE WILL REMAIN OPEN-MINDED.
HOW IS THIS DONE?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
ON THE BOTTOM OF THE PAN
REALLY LIGHTLY.
FLIP IT ONE TIME AND THEN
YOU MAKE A CRAB DRESSING,
ALMOST LIKE A MAYONNAISE
DRESSING.
>> YOU BASICALLY USE LUMP
CRAB.
SCRATCH.
EGG, MUSTARD, EVERYTHING IN
THERE AS WELL.
THEN YOU BASICALLY CREATE
THIS DRESSING WHICH IS SO
INTERESTING.
YOU JUST POP IT RIGHT ON TOP
OF THE OMELET COLD.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK THIS
IS -- I KNOW YOU ARE NOT A
CULTURAL ANTHROPOLOGIST IS
THIS SOMETHING WITHIN THE
REACH OF A HUNTER GATHERING
TRIBE IN THE SAUCE PANS, THE
WHOLE LUMP CRAB, THE
MAYONNAISE?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS
INSPIRED BY CERTAIN THINGS.
I'M NOT SURE OBVIOUSLY IF
YOU THINK ABOUT NATIVE
AND EATING WITH.
>> Tucker: THIS IS NOT WHAT
COMES TO MIND.
AS A PROFESSIONAL CHEF AND I
DON'T WANT TO YOU WEIGH IN
BECAUSE YOU ARE A
PROFESSIONAL AND WE DON'T
WANT TO SULLY THAT.
WHAT CULTURE CAME FIRST TO
MIND?
ELIZABETH WARREN OR ANOTHER.
>> WITH THE CRAB MEAT AND
THE FACT IT'S COLD IT GAVE
ME EUROPEAN INITIALLY WHEN I
WAS MAKING IT AND THEN ME
BEING A BREAKFAST GIEWR RYU,
THE OMELET JUST RINGS
AMERICAN TO MEAL.
ALL PERSONAL BREAKFAST FOOD.
>> Tucker: KEY TASTE IT.
>> SURE.
DEFINITELY.
>> I WANT TO KNOW, THIS IS
NOT A D.N.A. TEST.
23 AND ME.
NOT GETTING TO THE TRUTH OF
THIS NECESSARILY.
>> COLD OMELET WHICH IS
AGAIN VERY INTERESTING.
>> Tucker: I'M ABOUT TO TELL
YOU I CAN EAT THIS.
YOU LET ME KNOW.
I DON'T DABBLE TOO MUCH WITH
NATIVE AMERICAN COOKING.
BUT I WOULDN'T, THIS IS NOT
WHAT WOULD COME TO MIND
IMMEDIATELY.
AGAIN, I'M NOT AN EXPERT.
BUT IT'S GOOD.
THIS IS TRADITIONAL CHEROKEE
FOOD.
I COULD SEE WHY SHE WOULD
PRETEND TO BE A MEMBER OF
THIS.
SHE CONTRIBUTED TO POWWOW
CHOW.
>> NO, IT'S BREAKFAST IN
BED.
COOKING IN BOXERS.
FULLY DRESSED TODAY BECAUSE
IT'S COOK.
50 WAYS TO KEEP YOUR MATE IN
BED.
>> Tucker: SOMEONE ASKED TO
YOU CONTRIBUTE TO POWWOW
CHOW LIKE II EDITION WOULD
YOU DO THAT.
>> SURE DO A LITTLE
PLAGIARIZED RECIPE FROM A
FRENCH CHEF.
OWN TWIST WANT TO BE
INSPIRED.